[Música]
la maratón más antigua de Estados Unidos
Boston acoge desde 1897 uno de los
eventos más importantes del país la
carrera se lleva a cabo en un día de
fiesta y es un símbolo Nacional de
alegría y fraternidad
pero la edición de 2013 fue diferente
los explosiones en la línea de meta
convirtieron la celebración en una
tragedia
[Aplausos]
los artefactos detonaron dos horas
después de que el ganador cruzara la
línea de meta los más de 5.700
corredores aún no habían acabado tras
analizar la zona las autoridades
denominaron el hecho como un acto
terrorista y el FBI se hizo cargo de la
investigación
si buscaron intimidarnos aterrorizarnos
ya debería estar bastante Claro que
eligieron la ciudad equivocada para
hacerlo no aquí en Boston No aquí en
Boston Ese es el mensaje que enviamos a
los que llevaron a cabo esto y a
cualquiera que le haga daño a nuestra
gente sí los encontraremos Y sí
enfrentarán la justicia
los reportes iniciales apuntaron a dos
bombas de fabricación casera durante
días las agencias de inteligencia
analizaron miles de videos y cámaras de
seguridad identificando a dos
sospechosos tras difundir las imágenes
fueron identificados como taberland
sarnaev y su carta arnaev hermanos de
una familia de origen checheno residente
ambos en Estados Unidos desde 2003
el 19 de abril los dos sospechosos
asesinaron a un policía y secuestraron a
un joven de origen chino que finalmente
pudo escapar y los delató en el
enfrentamiento con la policía uno de los
sospechosos murió y el otro huyó al día
siguiente fue encontrado escondido en un
pequeño bote
tras la captura del segundo sospechoso
las calles de Boston se llenaron de
júbilo
[Aplausos]